Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today we're going to focus on a language
called Katelyn.
Katelyn is a member of the Occidental
Romance Branch of the Romance Language
family.
It's mainly spoken in and around
Catalonia and autonomous community in
spin as well as in another autonomous
community,
the Balearic islands,
and also in the autonomous community of
Valencia.
But some people will definitely dispute
that many members of the Valencian
community will insist that they speak a
separate language called Valencia and
others,
including most linguists,
simply considered Valencian to be a
collection of cattle and dialects.
Amanda,
um,
okay,
let's leave that issue aside for now.
But in any case,
in all three of those autonomous
communities cancel on his co official
with Spanish,
except in Valencia where it's co
official,
a Spanish under the name Valencian.
Oh Man.
This video just started and I've already
got a headache.
Cattle land has also spoken in the tiny
principality of Endora,
which is located in the Pyrenees
mountains and is bordered by France to
the north and Spain to the self.
Kendall land has also spoken across the
border in France,
in the northern Catalonia region.
Cattle land is closely related to
Oxytocin,
which is spoken in areas of France
adjacent to northern Catalonia.
In the past,
Katelyn and oxidant were considered to
be dialect groups of the same language,
but they're now widely considered to be
independent.
Sister languages have the same
Occidental Romance branch.
Katelyn has also spoken in the town of
[inaudible] ghetto in Sardinia,
Italy.
Katelyn is spoken by over 10 million
people,
some of whom indisputable.
He speak it as a native language and
some of whom speak another language at
home,
usually Spanish,
but are also fluent in cattle land and
speak at at a native level because of
their environment.
It's the sixth most spoken romance
language after Spanish,
Portuguese,
French,
Italian,
and Romanian.
It's also the most spoken nonstate
language in Europe,
meaning that it's the most spoken
language.
That's not an official language at the
national level.
That's because it's not official at the
national level in Spain,
even though millions of people speak it,
it's only official in endora.
Some people want it to be the official
language of a new country called
Catalonia that would be separate from
Spain.
Tell you what,
you can just google it and history like
all romance languages.
Katelyn developed from dialects of
vulgar Latin in areas that had been
under the control of the Roman Empire.
The earliest form of oxytocin or
romance,
no one has old oxy 10 or old provence
owl had developed by the eighth century
and later some of its varieties began to
diverge into old Katelyn.
Between the 10th and 14th centuries.
In the 12th century,
the county of Barcelona,
I can't,
Deland County formed a dynastic union
with the Kingdom of Aragon,
forming the crown of our goal and other
Catalan counties formed the Principality
of Catalonia together with Barcelona,
bringing them into the crown.
The crown of our gone expanded under the
rule of James the conqueror,
who brought Valencia and the Balearic
islands under the crown's control,
and these became Catalan speaking areas.
The political capital of the crown of
our goal was the city of Zaragoza in the
Kingdom of are gone,
but the defacto economic and cultural
centers where Barcelona and Valencia
both Kavalan speaking cities.
By the 14th and 15th centuries,
the crown of Aragona had greatly
expanded to include Corsica,
Sardinia,
Sicily,
and Naples.
And for a brief time,
Athens and Nail Patras.
In present day Greece,
there was a large cancel land commercial
presence throughout the Mediterranean
region and the Catalan language became
widespread,
at least amongst the commercial class.
Catelynn was considered one of the great
languages of Europe.
But in 1479 the crown of Aragon formed a
union with the crown of Casteel and
Castilian today also known as just the
Spanish or espanol,
began to grow in influence and cancel
and began to decline an influence.
During much of the period from the 16th
century to the 20th century,
various laws were enacted that limited
the use of cattle and in official
documents and publications in
administration and in schools.
But since 1975 it has been made co
official in Catalonia,
Valencia and the belly,
Eric Islands and in Catalonia schools
are now required to teach most subjects
in Catalan.
In Valencia,
there's less instruction and catelynn
known officially there as Valencian by
the way,
but there are current government efforts
to increase it in the belly.
Eric Islands,
at least 50% of the students schooling
must be conducted in Katelyn.
Though there are also programs that are
taught entirely in Katelyn,
all of the cattle land speaking
autonomous areas of Spain or bilingual
with Catalan speakers also being Spanish
speakers.
So what's Catalan like?
Once you learn one romance language,
you've already taken a great step
towards understanding the others.
If we look at a list of basic greetings
and capsule,
then there will definitely be some words
that speakers of other romance languages
will recognize immediately.
Good morning or good day on the,
ah,
that sounds an awful lot like
Portuguese,
Bom,
Dia and Spanish.
Buenos Dias.
Good afternoon [inaudible] compare that
with Portuguese and Spanish.
When I started this.
Good evening or good night.
Bye [inaudible] compare that with
Portuguese were annoyed that in Spanish
when us no chess and an Italian good
night would be worn or not dare to say
by you might say or they'll compare that
to Portuguese.
Are they all Spanish and French?
Add you and if you want to be more
formal you might say,
compare that with French oak of Wa.
Now let's look at some cattle and
sentences and examine some of the
languages.
Basic features,
many of which are quite similar to other
romance languages but with some
differences of course of Zeb is in
bumper fussell.
This means Joseph is a good teacher.
Oh,
Giussep is in bumper.
Fussell word for word.
It's the Joseph is a good teacher.
This sentence follows basically the same
word order you would find in other
romance languages and an English with
one difference.
The definite article all before the name
Joseph in Catalan,
a definite article is used before
people's first names and this is called
the personal article.
We'll come back to definite articles in
a minute.
This whole sentence is masculine,
singular,
like other romance languages,
cantillon nouns,
articles and adjectives are inflected
for grammatical,
gender and number.
Let's look at a similar feminine
sentence.
Laser Velez and I want to prefer Sota.
Isabel is a good teacher,
let of is and I want to prefer soda.
Feminine nouns generally and in a and
the adjectives that modify them are
inflected with a feminine ending a as
well.
While masculine nouns generally end in a
consonant or an o or I.
One other thing I want to point out here
is that the letter R is silent in the
final position in Katelyn,
so this word professoral ends in a vowel
sound.
There are basically four definite
articles.
The singular forms are all and la,
which changed to look with an
apostrophe.
If the following word starts with a
vowel or an h,
the plural forms are us and less for the
personal article.
There are the alternate forms and not
with an apostrophe before a vowel or an
h.
The indefinite articles are we not
wounds and Eunice,
the way articles work in Catelynn is
similar to another romance languages,
but the forms are different of course,
and there are also some dialectal
differences in Catalan articles.
Another sentence it yes,
and but of the animals.
Dot.
This means she always has lunch very
late,
a simpler the animal dot word for word,
it's,
she always has lunch very late.
One thing I'd like to point out right
off the bat is this phrase molded in
Spanish.
It would be week dot.
A day in Portuguese it would be winter
[inaudible].
In Italian it would be [inaudible] quite
similar to the candyland phrase,
but in the other languages,
words tend to end in vowels,
especially in Italian.
Words end in consonants much more often
than Katelyn,
but also pay attention to the
continents.
At the end of these words.
Here we see the simplification of final
consonant clusters.
T is often not pronounced after another
consonant at the end of a word,
especially in the combinations of Lt,
rt,
nt and St.
Sometimes it may be pronounced slightly
or articulated but not released and in
final position,
the letter d is pronounced as to but
similar to t it's often silent or
unreleased after another consonant.
Simplification of final consonant
clusters is a prominent feature of
Cadillac,
but it does not always happen and it
varies depending on the dialect.
The speaker in the samples speaks a
central Catalan dialect.
Here we have a personal pronoun as the
subject of the sentence.
This is actually not necessary.
Cantillon is a pro dropped language,
meaning that the subject pronouns can be
dropped because person a number are
clear from the verb conjugation like
other romance languages.
Katelyn has two types of personal
pronouns,
strong pronouns,
which are used as subject pronouns and
after prepositions.
The only difference being in the first
person singular and there are weak
pronouns,
which are clinics that are used for the
direct or indirect object.
Cattle then has more weak pronoun forums
than other major romance languages.
Just a note about this word [inaudible]
in this sentence it's pronounced as the
na because in Catalan d is pronounced as
the soft,
the sound between vowels.
Even though the D is in the initial
position here it is affected by the
vowel at the end of the previous word
did not is irregular verb meaning to
have lunch and here it's conjugated in
the third person singular for the
present tense.
Katelyn has three categories of regular
verbs which are characterized by
different endings.
Verb ending in Ar,
also known as the first conjugation verb
ending in our e or er,
the second conjugation and verbs ending
in irr.
The third conjugation verbs in each
category have the same or similar
conjugations.
Another sentence,
mother nothin's [inaudible] this means
he gave me the money this morning,
mother,
not those dienes I couldn't Mati word
for word.
It's to me has given the masculine
plural money this morning.
The first word ma is a week Pronoun,
which is used for the indirect object
here.
This form of the Pronoun m apostrophe
comes before vowels and the letter h
while before consonants.
It's m as in m.
Notice that it comes before the verb.
Other not is the perfect form of the
verb do na the perfect form includes the
auxiliary verb of a followed by the past
participle.
It's used for events in the recent past
and events within timeframes that are
connected to now like this month or this
year.
There are parallel tenses in other
romance languages and cattle and system
of verb tenses in general is very
similar to other romance languages.
Do not is another example of a Catalan
word ending in a continent where it
would end with a vowel in other romance
languages.
In Italian,
this would be a little bottle and in
Spanish it would be the model in
Romanian,
however it would be donut.
Next,
notice the masculine plural definite
article because the word for money,
dns is plural.
The word a kid is similar to Italian
Cuesta or Spanish and Portuguese Esta,
but notice that the s and t are
pronounced differently.
The S is silent in the tea is not
released.
Mati is similar to Italian Martina or
French natal.
Coming back to the week pronouns for a
minute.
What if we want to use a pronoun in
place of [inaudible]?
Whether or not that can mati the direct
object in this case,
oh,
meaning it must come after the indirect
object week.
Pronouns come after the verb.
In the case of imperatives,
at least positive imperatives,
jurrens and infinitives,
so the imperative sentence give it to me
would be gona move another sentence.
It is about going to the AFI.
Those ans this means he graduated two
years ago.
Word for word.
It's reflexive Pronoun.
He graduated,
makes two years.
Remember that the subject Pronoun l is
probably not necessary.
Let's look at the end of the sentence
first.
This phrase here,
Father's ons shows the use of the verb
fe meaning to make to tell how much time
has passed since then event happened.
This is similar to how it would be
expressed in Italian.
Do a on the far as about a lot of the
work is a past tense construction called
the pair of rustic past that is unique
to Katelyn.
It consists of an auxiliary verb related
to but not identical to the present
tense of the verb.
ONA meaning to go followed by a verb in
the infinitive.
The pair of frantic past is identical
and meaning to the simple past which is
now normally limited to literary use.
Note that the reflexive pronoun in a
different form can appear after the verb
instead if it's an infinitive or an
imperative or general.
So this could also be boggled of the
water sup and the whole sentence could
be a bug.
A lot of the water [inaudible].
This verb construction is somewhat
surprising to me because it looks quite
similar to the paraphrase stick future.
Using anon out of the waterside means he
is going to graduate with va being the
third person singular present tense of
ONA.
This [inaudible] future form is used
lefts and Katelyn.
Then in some other romance languages
probably because it resembles the pair
of frantic past.
So instead the simple future can be used
as a good of the water.
He will graduate in Catalan.
You typically formed the simple future
tense by adding a suffix to the
infinitive form,
but for some irregular verbs there is a
different future stem,
not the infinitive.
In general,
the way the cattle and verbs are
conjugated is quite similar to other
romance languages except that the exact
forms are somewhat different with
Western romance languages in general.
If you speak one or if you've studied
one than the other,
seems somewhat familiar right off the
bat,
but on the other hand,
everything seems somewhat different as
well.
There's some different vocabulary,
different phonology,
some different grammatical features and
sometimes things are just expressed
differently.
Being previously unfamiliar with Katelyn
for the most part,
what strikes me is that I noticed
features that are similar to Spanish to
French,
to Italian,
to Portuguese into Romanian,
but I would never confuse it with one of
those languages because it has its own
unique elements as well.
The question of the day for speakers of
Katelyn,
what other romance languages do you find
closest to Katelyn?
Can you communicate with Occitan
speakers easily or Italian speakers,
et Cetera,
and for speakers of other romance
languages?
How familiar does Catalan seem to you?
What differences stand out to you?
Special thanks to my friend Pablo who
helped with the audio samples for this
video.
He's from the Catalonia region of Spain
and he's fluent in Catalan,
Spanish,
English,
Japanese,
and I believe some other languages too.
And he's a brilliant guy.
In general.
If you're studying Spanish or if you
want to study Spanish,
I recommend you check out his channel,
dreaming Spanish,
where you can learn Spanish using his
unique approach to language learning.
So check it out.
Be sure to follow Lang,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram.
And once again,
thank you to all of my amazing patrion
supporters,
especially these ones because they are
the best patrons in the world.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.